本当に はい よろしくお願いします
人生は大変苦しいものであるとお釈迦様はおっしゃっていますから
結局は講演会も大変苦しいものですね
講演会ぐらいはちょっと楽になった方がいいんじゃないかなとは自分はありますけど
もうなかなか何でもかんでも苦しくなる時代になっています
で 一応時間もかなり進んでしまいましたので
さっさとお話に入ります
いろいろスライドを見えないとか
いろいろ問題点がありますから
全然心配しないでください
今日は別にスライドを見ても見なくてもどうでもいい話になります
十分簡単な話になります
今日はあえてお釈迦様の経典とかは引用しないんです
で 全く世間話になりますので
それならあなたよりは私の方が上手でしょうってこともあるでしょうと思いますけど
そういうことだから 気楽に聞いてみてください
なすならば この まあちょっとした仕事問題ですからね
あの そんなにあの馴染みがない
何でになっちゃったっけ？知らないうちに落ちちゃったっけな
馴染みのない話でもございません
はい そういうことでまあ
話に入ります まずは問題点ということで
まあ今日我々考える問題点ですね
まあ個人編で えーと まあ自分に適した仕事は何でしょうかっていうね
よくわからないと  これっていうのは当たり前のことですね
それは一つの問題点で
好きな仕事はあるが就職できない
これも私たちには結構ある問題で
次 特別な好みはない 何でもやります
しかし 雇ってくれない
これも最近の問題で もう何でもいいんだから仕事をくれと
とは言うんだけど なかなか
雇ってくれないんですね
それから仕事はあるんだけど
全然面白くないと これも大きな問題なんですよ
それから仕事に問題はないんだけど
人々の性格がね なかなか合わないと
こういう問題も私たちにはありますよ
仕事は別にやるとこないわけじゃなくて
やっぱり仲間がね 仲間じゃないんですね
そういうことはあります
それから 今の仕事では収入が足らないと
まあ一応なんとか仕事はしていますけど
もう仲間ともう切ってますけど
収入はね これでは生きていられないという問題もあります
転職したいが 自信はないんですね
いろいろ理由があって
例えばもう両親が田舎に戻って来いとかいろいろ言われたりしたりして
あるいはもっといい仕事を見つけたいとかね
転職したくなるんだけど
どうも自信がなくて いいのか
転職ではとかね という疑問も浮上出てきます
ストレスが溜まりすぎて病気になりそう
これもありますね で 仕事はやってますが
もう毎日ストレスが溜まって
この調子ならもう大変なことになるんだぞという
仕事は忙しくて あまりにも難しい仕事をやったりして
ものすごいストレス溜まったりする
で このストレス溜まる人々っていろいろあるんですね
仕事はもうできなくてね
もうすごい苦しいんで
そこはストレスになったりもするし
もうこの仲間があまりうまくいかないとね
いじめとかいろいろあると
また仕事は簡単であってもストレス溜まったりする
あるいはもう本当に仕事は大変ですということでできるんですけど
かなり大変責任が多い仕事でも
もうやっているとどんどんストレス溜まったりして
結構病気になる方々もいますよ
なので 仕事の要求に期待に対応できない人々もいます
もう会社の方があれやってくれ
これやってくれ これぐらいやってくれとかいろいろ言われますけど
何か企画作ってくれとかね
売り上げを上げる方法なんか考えてくれとか
いろいろ期待はするんだけど
自分にはどうもそこまではできるわけじゃない
できないんですね できないんだから言って無理やりできませんと言えないでしょうに
だから悩み始めになっちゃうんですね
そういうことで 会社とか雇った側の期待にしっかりと応じることはできないということで
その能力は向上しないんですね
能力というのは上がるはずなんですけど
なかなか自分の能力は上がりそうもないという状態もあります
殺陣ばかり頼まれている気がすると
よく女性たちの悩みを聞く場合はよく言われたことで
会社でなんか殺陣ばっかりやらせているんだというね
で そうなってくると また仕事には問題が起こるんですね
できない やりにくい きつい仕事ばかり
自分の仕事はもう本当にできない
あんな仕事をできないということもあるし
やりにくい あるいはきつい
きつすぎ どうしようかというふうに悩んでいる場合もあります
そんな程度ですね じゃあとにかく問題点というのは
これは あの 本で言えば前書きのようなものでですから
さっさと言います 次 問題点はこの雇主の辺ですね
雇う側にもいろいろ問題がありますよ
人手が余っているという問題もあって
足らないということもありますね
一部は余っていて もうどうしようもなくて
一部はもう人手がないんだと
仕事を理解しない 雇ったんだけど
どうもこの人は理解してくれないんだね
仕事を それがよくあるんです
やる気がないんだと この社員たちには
命令に従わない 自分勝手
言う通りにやらない なんか自分勝手にいろんなことをやったりする
これはやっぱり社長 課長
部長というのはかなり嫌がりますよ
言われる言われたことだけやるが
そうそう世話はない はい
右 33 3 3  30センチ進んでくださいと言えば
ちょうど測って 30センチで止まるというような
もう人間は結構いるんですよ
で やっぱり雇う側にとってはね
例えば何か品物を持って
こういう店に行って こういうこういうものを買ってこいと頼んだら
その店に行って そちらはなかったと堂々と帰るんです
そうすると 命令した人は
それだったらまたあちこち電話連絡して
別なところじゃああちらに行ってくださいと言わなくちゃいけないので
もう嫌でしょうね そんな社員が
だからまあ どこかに行って
こういう品物を仕入れてくださいといったら
そちらがなかったら そこでさっさと何か調べてちゃんと持ってくるならば
まあそれはすごくいいことなんですけど
何をできる人かと読めない
例えば新入社員なんかは
育てる場合はもうこの人ならこれができて
この人ならこれにやった方がやった方がいいかというふうに管理側が読めないと
それで管理の人々はもう読めを読んでみようかなと思っちゃうけど
なかなかこれはもうもう仮面をかぶっていて
もう笑ったりも泣いたりも何もない
感情も何もない もう全然読めないんですね
これ結構現代人にありますよ
全く何者か読めない 作った人間みたいですね
それから適任はいないというね
いろいろもうしっかりした育てたいのですが
それなりの人が出てこないという問題もあります
えーと 必要ですが 赤字で人を雇えないんだと
時々いろいろ会社あるんですよ
ちょっとした仕事をするために何人かの手が必要なんです
しかし 品物はなかなか売れ行きが下がったりして
収入がないんですね ないんだけど
ほんのちょっとの注文にも
それでも何人かの人手が必要なんです
それを雇いちゃうと給料を払わなくちゃいけないし
これもどうにもならんですね
だから赤字ですね その場合は
例えばもう 100個売れれば
もうみんなに何とか給料を払えるんだけど
注文はもう 60個しか注文がないと
しかし 人は10人が必要なんですね 60
個作るか 100個作るか 10
人が必要なんです そうすると60個の注文では 10
人で仕事をすると もう赤字
むちゃくちゃ赤字なんですね
ですから 10人雇いたんだけど
どうすればいいかと もうこんな調子ではというもう問題もありますね
人の管理できないと これあんまり日本ではないかもしれませんだけど
外国で結構あるんですね
もう我儘でストやったり
デモやったり あれやこれやとかね
もう仕事はしないんです
社員の能力を上げる方法はわからない
どうすれば生産能力を上げるのか
どうすれば人々にやる気を出させるのかという能力は管理者にない場合もあります
採算が合わないということはよくわかりますね
資金の獲得できないと
消費者の獲得できない
いわゆる売れないということですね
競争で負けると 他のライバル会社に競争で負けてしまうとかね
もうなどなどありますよ
全部もう皆さん別にもう課長
社長ではないんだから
まあそこら辺は省略します
それはどちらにせよ 私やったことないんだからね
それでそういうことがいくつか我々は考えなくちゃいけない問題はあります
答えはどうしますかね
そういう問題に これは論理的には答えありますよ
具体的に実行できるんですかね
そういう 今私は出した質問には答えがないわけないんだけど
ただ頭だけの答えですね
実際実行できるかというね
回答があっても その場
その時に限るんです 普遍的に役に立たないんです
したがって 仏教的な回答にはならないんです
答えを出しても 一つ一つにあまり仏教的な答えにはならないんですよ
全部その時その時の答えで
ですから ブッダが語る中世中小の立場で観察を心得るしかないのです
で 今日の話は まあこちらはとにかく仏教の話ですから
あの仏教の話にしなきゃダメし
経営者に向かって喋るならば
もうちょっと俗世間のことを言ってもいいんだけど
ちょっともう一度考えてみますけど
あの 適した仕事は何でしょうか？とよくわからないということにね
答えは簡単です とにかく仕事をしろよと
適した仕事とかね そんなことを言っている場合じゃないんです
仕事をしていく過程で
自分に適しているかどうかがわかるんですね
で  2番目だったら 好きな仕事はあるが就職できないと
だったら辞めるしかないでしょうに
他の仕事に行くしかないんですよ
とにかく好きな仕事を何とかもうとにかくそちらに入りたい
入ると雇ってくれないんだから
まあいらんと それだったらもう別の仕事に行くしかないんですよ
特別な好みはない 何でもやりたい
しかし 雇ってくれないっていうのは
これ この何でもやりますという言葉がすごく臭いんですよ
私は嫌なんですよ 何でもやりますという人をね
すごいですね 結構です
で あの日本ではそういう経験ないんだけど
まあ国に行ったらもう飛び入り人が来て
もう何かもうもうもう仕事がなくて困ってるんだから
何か仕事はないんですか？とお寺に言ったら
あんたに何かできるんですかと
何でもやりますからと言ったら
結構ですと みんないますから
若者ならね もうあいつらにもうもうむちゃくちゃ仕事をさせなくちゃいけないんだから
もう帰ってちょうだい
すぐもう だからこの何でもやりますということは
すごく臭い言葉なので使わない方がいいんです
だって何をやらせればいいかわからないですよ
雇う 雇う人にとっては具体的な仕事があるんですよ
これこれやってほしいって具体的なことがありまして
この便利屋さんが入るともうむちゃくちゃになるんです
だから決してこの何でもやりますという言葉だけではうまくいかないとよく覚えておいてください
あの 皆様にはもしかすると関係ないかもしれませんだけど
若者がいるならばね まあそれを言ってあげてください
あるいはまあ 今就職を探さなくちゃいけない場合でもね
あの 例えばもう面接に呼ばれたら
このまあ何でもできますからとかね
何でもやりますということだけは言わない方がいいんです
だから答えは何なのかと私には言えますけど
その場でその場の答えだから
あまり言いたくはないんですよ
例えばもう例えば私はこういうこういう仕事をしてきました
だからだからこういうこういうことならば結構自信がある
しかし 今の状況ではね
そんなことは言えませんだから
あの 適当にできる範囲のことを頼んでください
あの 何と言いますか もう
失望はさせませんよと
雇って良かったと思えるようにやりますよと
で まあそういう感じでいくらか固めてくれないと
次のことだったら まあ仕事はあるが面白くないとね
それってとっても良くないことなんですね
こんな仕事面白くないとかなれば
まあクビにさせさせますね
仕事っていうのは面白いか面白くないか
そんなことじゃないんですよ
大事なことなんです だからこのすごく勘違いなんです
面白いことやりたければ
パチンコ屋にでも行けばいいでしょうに
だからなんでそんなことを考えるんですかね
もうあの 最近はそんなことを考えられる状況じゃないんだけど
まあちょっと前はもうそういうことね
面白くないんだとかね
だから真剣さがないんですね
仕事っていうのは大事なことで
そんなふざけて遊んでやれるものじゃないんです
だから 仕事に面白いと面白くないっていうことは持ってくるものじゃないんです
お医者さんが手術は面白くないということと同じでしょうに
もう汚いものばっかり
毎日毎日触ったりして
で 面白くない 毎日患者さんばっかりですよと
そんなこと言ってる場合じゃないんです
すごい真剣にやらなくちゃいけないんですよ
だからそれはもう本当に思ってはならない言葉で
で まあ人々の性格が合わないということは
自分が悪いということでね
もう人々とわがままで頑固で
俺の機嫌を取ってくださいという調子ではね
社会では生きていられませんだからね
だからそれはもうしつけまで間違っている可能性ありますよ
人は性格が合わない 合わないというのは
まだ人間として失敗なんです
大人になったということは
その人のどんな性格の人であっても
もうぶつからないで 何か何とか調和を保って
生きることなんです 別に 24時間付きっきりで一緒にいるわけじゃないでしょうに
あえて結婚した相手でも
そんなべったり 24時間一緒にいないでしょうに
ほんの短い時間でしょうに
結婚したってても 相手というのは
例えば夜家に帰ったら
また朝出かけるまでの時間でしょうに
そこで喧嘩するならば
その短い時間に もうしつけが悪いでしょうに
だからまあ 会社に行ったら
それ何時間ぐらいいるだけのことで
その時間でまあまあ問題起こらないように
自分が自分を育てなくちゃいけないんですよ
えーと 今の仕事では収入が足らない
収入が足らないということはね
だから簡単ですね 別の仕事に行ってください
でも それは簡単答えじゃないんですよ
確実にもしかするとそうかもしれませんよ
収入がある仕事があるならば
そちらに悩んでないで行ってますからね
特に仕事はもう収入が足らないで悩んでる人には
他の仕事がないということは明確なんです
収入がもっとある仕事はないんです
だから悩んでるんです
だからどうすればいいんですかね
収入に生活を合わせなくちゃいけないんですよ
いつでも人間っていうのは勘違いなんですよ
収入っていうのはいくらでも入るものじゃないんです
世の中でいろんな人々がいます
ものすごく仕事をしても
収入は少ない まあ特に仕事をしていないんだけど
バンバン収入が入るとかね
すごく頭が良くて ものすごいことをやってますけど
全然もう何も入らなくて
しかしもう社長がいるんですけど
もう中学も特に卒業してないとかね
それでもものすごい儲かっているんだとかね
その分仕事もしないと社員ばっかり働かせてるとか
そういうもう世の中でいろいろですよ
収入の場合は で 法律違反で捕まる時もいろいろですよ
ものむちゃくちゃ法律を犯しているのに捕まらない
もう警察庁には全然興味ない
ほんのわずかな間違いが起こっただけで
いきなり飛んできて捕まってむちゃくちゃもう裁く場合もありますよ
それはまあ もうどうにもならんですよ
まあ例えばもう政治資金ももう法律も不正的なことをやったといえば
まあみんなやってますけど
政治家なら議員であっても
選挙で負けた人であっても
政治家ならもうお金はすべて不正でもらった取ったものなんです
そんな人間がありがたく
はい あげますとか 誰も思ってもないんです
皆さんあげたことある？政治資金 1万円ぐらいでもないでしょうね
もし皆様あげた じゃあまあ 5,000円ぐらいはもうこの党にあげられますということだから
これは正しい もう合法的な政治資金で誰もあげてないでしょう
しかし どれぐらい金持ってます？だから完璧にあれは不正でもらったものですよ
しかし 捕まるのは そのその時
その時潰したい人だけなんです
だからそれにガチャガチャ何言ったっても
もうどうにもならんことなんですよ
世の中のことっていうのは
だからって何か言って何か通じると思いますか？どうにもならん
もう調べたらやってますから
しょうがないでしょうに
でも私だけではないんだと言ったっても
それはあまり通じない話なんですよ
もう他の人もやってるかもしれませんだけど
とりあえずあなたは有罪やと
そのうち暇があったら他の人々も調べますよと言ったらどうします？だからまあ
そういうことにはあの文句言ったって私はあんまり意味がないと思いますよ
そこでちょっと余計なことを言いましたけど
あの 我々個人の収入 についても同じことですよ
私とこの人は同じ大学出たんだと
私の方がどう見たっても優秀でしたと
しかし 私の収入はもう 30万円で
この人はもう 60万円つくしでもらっているんだと
倍のお高い これ不正やとか
それこれ言っていたって
だからこの他人の収入を見て自分の設計生活を企画するんじゃないんですよ
これよく日本の方々はやっている
とんでもない失敗なんです
で あの普通のこの家庭の奥様たちのように
収入を見て これはどうやって使うのかと
だから我々には買う食料の管理できるし
で 電気を消したりすることはできるし
電気代高いんだから みんな 1箇所で仕事をしましょうよと
勉強 あんたはこちら勉強しなさいよとかね
あんたゲームやりたければ
あんたはそちらでゲームやってくださいと
で 旦那さんも奥さんも子供もみんな 1箇所で
一つの蛍光灯で仕事したっても
だからそこは個人に管理できないのでできますよ
収入はそれできないんですね
だから家に 3人いるんだからといっても
部屋 3つで暖房 3つつけちゃったりして
テレビは 3台あったりして
だから収入足らない 収入足らないと
それって理想 論理的じゃないでしょうに
そういうとんでもない無茶なことをして文句を言ったってもね
助けてあげる方法はないんです
だから仏教的に言えば
この我々もちゃんと理性を持って
自分で調整できるものは自分で調整する
しかし 調整できないものについては自分を合わせるしかないんです
収入が足らないんだったら
もっと収入が高い仕事あるなれば行くんだから
別に私が言わなくたっても
そういう文句を時々私にも言われるのは
そういう仕事はないんだからな
特に仕事を変えたいと私に言う
アドバイスも相談する人々っていうのは
まあまあ ただちょっと応援してほしいだけなんですね
別にもうどうったことはないんだけど
私はもうもうもうそういうこと言われるの嫌なんですけど
まあとにかくもうああいいですよとか何とか言ってくれれば
気持ちよく仕事を変えてひどい目に遭う可能性もあるし
で だから私はそういうことは言いません
私は仕事を変える理由は具体的に
というふうに 今の仕事の問題点は
それから 新しく入ろうとする人はなんで選んだんですか？と
そちらになる長所は何でしょうか？と
それ質問するだけで そうすると相手にちょっとだけでも論理性があるならば
そこを判断して 何か判断することはできると思いますね
まあ仕事が足らない 収入が足らないという人であっても
同じことでまあですよ
で 転職自体は自信がないんだったらしないことでしょうね
自信がなかったら転職したって意味がないしね
まあストレスを溜めすぎてっていうのは
それは簡単に答えられませんだから
あの どういう状況でなぜストレスを溜めるのかということを調べなくちゃいけないんですね
これはね どうにもならないんですね
こういう人は転職した方がいいです
収入がいくら下がったってもしょうがないんです
自分にできる仕事を簡単な仕事を探すんじゃないんです
これは勘違いですね ちょっと傲慢というかね
察知ばかりばかり頼まれるんだったらいいんですよ
自分が本当に大学を出て
いろいろ肩書きあったりしたっても
一旦入った会社で察知ばっかりだったらやればいいんです
その方が楽です だからこれ勘違いです
なぜかというと 私はそんなほんのもうもう
大学で仕事をしましたけど
まあ一応向こうは大学
全部政府のものだからね
まあだから政府の担われていることになりますけどね
えー私は喜んで察知やっていたんです
時々自分の仕事をね まあ授業をやることやらね
いろいろ調べてレポートを出すことやら
できればそのそれをごまかしたい
ごまかすんじゃなくて
あの こういうこういうことだからね
他の誰かに頼んでくださいと
そういう調子で察知は好きでしたけどね
あれ結構楽しいんです
いろんな他の人々と一緒にあって
この この普通にあの労働とかね
掃除とか いろんな事務所の普通の仕事にね
雇っている人々いるんですよ
だから学校も大学も出たわけでも何ともなく
もうただの人々と喋っていると結構面白いんですよ
この知識人というよりも
だから教授たちばっかりでお茶飲んだり喋ったりしても
それよりはあの連中と喋ったりするとすごく面白いし
それで私が仲間みたいな感じで一緒になっていると
みんなすごく喜ぶんですね
だからアカデミックスタッフというのは管理格が高いんです
で ご飯食べる時もあれも分けてます
スタッフレストランって別にあるんです
そちらは普通の人は誰も入れません
だから結構落ち着いて静かで
だからこの偉い連中ばっかりでいるよりは全く難しくない
普通の労働をしている人と一緒にどこかに腰をかけて
がちゃがちゃ ものすごい勉強になるんです
だから私も好きでしたけどね
これはちょっと傲慢というかね
調子に乗りすぎて これ好きできない
やりにやりにくい きついっていうのはね
怠けだけですからね 怠け者には不幸になるって決まってますからね
あの雇い主に答えあります
あの